rose wade on se connaît désolé de vous
déranger mais quand j'appelle votre
équipe me dit que vous n'êtes pas
disponible
vous pourriez en faire plus pour nos
concitoyens
[Musique]
vous venez d'une longue lignée de
philanthropes et à ma connaissance vous
ne faites pas votre part
[Musique]
leader il veut vous parler le tueur a
laissé sa pour batman pourquoi il
s'adresse à vous
voilà
je cherchais avoue jours
c'est la dernière du riddler c'est plein
de références owen il faut qu'on résiste
sinon personne ne frappe j'avais un
statut j'aime les bêtes qui errent dans
les rues
le battait la cat
[Musique]
ça me vient c'est une nouvelle amie
je n'en suis pas si sûr
mon seul peut-être été masqué la vérité
sans ce cloaque qui nous sert de pilules
vous êtes impliqué le procès démarre
quand ils voient suis impliqué
vous êtes bien moins intelligents que je
ne pensais boss
wayne
pendant toutes ces années
vous m'avez menti alfred
nous avons tous nos blessures bros mais
vous restez un wayne
il est appliqué dans tout ça mais non
dans sa voix saint tite qui fait justice
lui même
qui êtes vous là dessous
qu'est-ce que vous cachez céline a
dégagé pas votre avis
vous en faites pas à mon chou j'en ai
neuf en tout
elle peut être cruel aveugle ou
inachevées
mais qui en est privée à voir la
violence se lever
à justice c'est ça la bonne réponse
allez bon genre
[Musique]
on va chercher des ennuis